I bet you're confused when it comes to
the different types of cooking oils
which is healthy which should you avoid
what are the health benefits and how to
use it to make things a little less
confusing I'm gonna share with you some
of the facts about the top 10 most
common cooking oils all cooking oils are
composed of three different types of
fatty acids monounsaturated
polyunsaturated and saturated fats so
each oil is categorized based on which
fatty acid is most prominent in it so
before we get started let's understand
the difference between monounsaturated
polyunsaturated and also saturated fats
mono unsaturated fats are typically
liquid at room temperature but may
solidify when chilled it can help to
reduce bad cholesterol levels and also
it is high in vitamin E so olive oil and
avocado oil are considered mostly mono
unsaturated fats there are two main
types of polyunsaturated fats omega-3
fatty acids and also omega-6 fatty acids
which are both essential to maintain a
healthy body
so grapeseed oil is high in
polyunsaturated fats saturated fats are
typically found in animal products such
as meat or dairy but they are also found
in some plant sources such as coconut
oil these fats are typically solid at
room temperature so let's start with
olive oil regular olive oil has an
unremarkable smell and a neutral palate
it has a high smoke point at 465
Fahrenheit making it one of the most
versatile cooking ones it is great for
sauteing pan frying grilling deep frying
and even great as a salad dressing
olive oil is known for its heart-healthy
benefits it is high in vitamin E and
also monounsaturated fats
however it is very important to note
that extra virgin olive oil should not
be used for cooking extra virgin olive
oil is processed by Co pressing with
temperatures no higher than 80 point 5
Fahrenheit which means it is richer in
antioxidants nutrients and also flavors
has a slight fruity bitter II and also
peppery taste and always remember to
keep your olive oil in a cold dark and
dry place to avoid it from going rancid
the next oil is coconut oil coconut oil
is nearly colorless and has a very light
coconut taste and aroma which you will
taste in your cooking coconut oil has
the highest amount of saturated fats
with more than 90% what this also means
is that it is very resistant to heat
making it extremely versatile it is
great for frying sauteing and great as a
butter replacement in baked recipes
especially for vegans so what are the
benefits coconut oil is high in vitamin
E K iron an especially high in a fatty
acid called lauric acid which can
actually help to raise your good
cholesterol and kill harmful bacteria
viruses and fungi and the fatty acid is
also believed to help reduce hunger now
let's move on to flaxseed oil which is
also known as linseed oil it has a clear
golden yellow color and has a strong
nutty and bitter taste which is
certainly not everybody's favorite you
shouldn't be cooking with flaxseed oil
use it in small quantity as a salad
dressing or add into smoothies because
too much can have a very strong taste
and also aroma it contains high amounts
of omega-3 fatty acids especially our
FAL in oleic acid which is important for
proper functioning of the brain and also
hot consuming it on a daily basis can
also help treat constipation and improve
on your overall digestive system the
food oil is avocado oil the composition
of avocado oil is very similar to olive
oil and can be used just like olive oil
its vibrant green and has a very subtle
buttery flavor with the hint of avocado
it has one of the highest smoke points
of any oils at 510
Fahrenheit making it the best choice for
super high cooking such as grilling of
frying but it can also be drizzled on to
salads almost 70% of avocado oil
consists of heart-healthy oleic acid a
mono unsaturated omega-9 fatty acid it
helps to improve heart health and reduce
bad cholesterol levels it is also high
in lutein and antioxidant that help to
boost eye health and reduce any
age-related eye diseases now let's talk
about grapeseed oil some researchers
would categorize grapeseed as a healthy
oil whereas others would say to avoid it
while grapeseed oil has its benefit and
also it's bad sight let's start with the
good grapeseed oil has a good amount of
vitamin E in fact it has doubled the
amount of vitamin E compared to olive
oil however grapeseed oil has one of the
highest amount of omega-6 in comparison
to other vegetable oils omega-6 isn't
bad by nature however too much of
omega-6 in our diet can cause
inflammation increases cholesterol and
caused hormone imbalance the bottom line
is grapeseed oil is a better alternative
for olive oil compared to other
vegetable oils it is also a cheaper
alternative it is virtually flavorless
and odorless which will not alter the
taste of a recipe but use in small
amounts sesame oil is a favorite oil
used in Asian cooking it has a dark
brown color and a toasted nutty flavor
it has a high smoke point making it an
extremely versatile oil but remember to
keep it in the fridge after using it has
high amounts of nutrients including
magnesium calcium zinc potassium and
folate this helps to improve bone health
and boosts circulation now let's take a
look at some of the worst cooking oils
which you think might be healthy canola
oil canola oil might be high in omega-3
fatty acids and low in saturated fats
but it is genetically modified from
rapeseed oil and it's very cheap to
manufacture
hence a large part have already turned
into trans fat it is a refined oil that
is often partially hydrogenated to
increase its stability but this also
increases its negative health effects
peanut oil is commonly referred to as
ground nut oil it has a very high smoke
point and is commonly used in Asian
cooking the restaurants and fast food
joints love it the issue here is that
most of the commercialized peanut oils
you get in grocery stores are highly
refined durai's and bleached so unless
you're able to sauce for the
cold-pressed unrefined version avoid it
sunflower oil is the most commonly used
cooking oil in the world however it does
not contain a significant amount of
minerals or vitamins
Industrial sunflower oil is highly
processed refined and may even contain
trans fats regular consumption of
sunflower oil can lead to heart diseases
high cholesterol levels and other
serious illnesses you should not be
cooking with sunflower oil in fact you
should just avoid it finally if you come
across the vegetable oil well simply
avoid it again it is highly processed
and may be a blend of many different
oils here are the cooking oils which you
should avoid altogether I'm good to
share with you some of the do's and also
don'ts the first rule of thumb is as
much as you can buy the raw unrefined
version avoid highly processed cooking
oils due to the high levels of toxic
chemicals always use cooking oils in
moderation store them in a cool and dry
area away from direct sunlight some oils
have to be stored in the fridge such as
avocado oil flaxseed oil and a sauce
sesame oil so do read the instructions
so I hope that this video has helped you
to better understand some of the most
common cooking oils which to use wish to
avoid and the right way to use them
don't forget to give this video a thumbs
up share this information on and
subscribe to my youtube channel for a
lot more nutritional tips do check out
more useful videos right
all the best